right I finally got my hands on it this
is Tesla's newest piece of merch a 300
wireless charger now you might have seen
the headlines about this being hailed as
like Tesla making air power where Apple
failed and it's kinda like that but not
exactly so what it is is a collaboration
with a company called free Power whose
Tech is basically using a bunch of
overlapping coils and really clever
software to give you the ability to
place your device anywhere on the mat
and it'll direct your charge it's pretty
sick it works well and you can actually
drop up to three things on here up to 15
watts each just no Apple watch since
that's not QI charging but actually just
as impressive as the tech is the build
quality this is actually the best built
wireless charger I've ever used so it
has this angular aluminum design kind of
like a cyber truck and then this
Alcantara surface like the headliner and
the cars even the brick and the flat
cable built in look kind of cybery and
then there's this metal stand with
magnets that lets you prop it up at
different angles and it is Rock Solid is
this worth 300 bucks probably not but
this probably is the first time Tesla's
had the best built product in any
category